deux ministres en alsace jeudi nathalie
l'oiseau pour les affaires étrangères et
sébastien lecornu en charge de la
transition énergétique
ils ont rencontré le ministre président
du bade wurtemberg pour évoquer la
coopération franco allemande mais le
principal dossier du jour était bien sûr
la fermeture de fessenheim sébastien
lecornu y est attendu demain
cet après-midi ils étaient en allemagne
pour découvrir un exemple de
reconversion industrielle
c'est là à eschbach que l'on retrouve en
direct stéphane gaudry stéphane bron
soir sébastien lecornu at il déjà donné
de nouvelles précisions concernant faire
la fermeture de fessenheim
il était censé annoncer un calendrier
lors de ce deuxième voyage et on peut
dire que cette question-là bien
embarrassé aujourd'hui car vous le savez
l'agencé de sûreté nucléaire a révélé de
nouvelles malfaçons sur le chantier de
l'epr de flamanville les malfaçons qui
pourrait retarder l'ouverture de le père
et donc c'est retarder la fermeture de
fessenheim
du coup le ministre lui a préféré
insister vous allez l'entendre sur
l'irréversibilité de la décision de
fermeture c'est d'autorités de sûreté
nucléaire qui va venir clarifier les
choses pour flamanville et puis en
fonction de ce que l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire dira sur flamanville
on sera en situation de clarifier le
calendrier pour fessenheim
une fois de plus il ya beaucoup de tanks
étaient perdus sur ce dossier vous avez
vu que depuis le mois de janvier
l'ensemble des sous-traitants de la
centrale ont été reçus par la cellule de
reclassement
vous avez vu qu'un accord a été trouvé
entre la direction d'edf et les
représentants syndicaux de la centrale
de fessenheim
ça y est les réversibilité du principe
de toute façon il est posé
alors vous l'avez entendu le secrétaire
d'état a ainsi insisté aussi sur le
chantier de reconversion du bassin
c'est pour ça qu'ils étaient ici en
allemagne sur cette base dans cette
ancienne base qui accueillent
aujourd'hui 170 entreprises qui
voudraient bien s'étendre de notre côté
du rhin seulement les allemands pour ça
dans des conditions écouter brigitte
klinkert et la réponse du secrétaire
d'état
donc nous avons des terrains nous avons
des salariés possible et alors leur
demande serait que l'état étudie la
possibilité d'une zone franco allemande
une zone à statut fiscal particulier et
surtout une zone à statut de droit du
travail particulier voilà leur demande
pour faire de cette zone une vraie zone
européenne franco allemand vous avez des
mécanismes aujourd'hui qui permettent de
dd des implantations d'entreprises
enfin le commissaire à l'égalité des
territoires plein d'outils qui sont sur
la table en matière fiscale et en
matière sociale il faut juste bien
choisir les dispositifs comme d'ailleurs
dans le cadre de la réflexion que nous
avons autour de la mise à jour en
quelque sorte du traité de l'élysée
entre la france et l'allemagne
demain le secrétaire d'état rencontrera
notamment les syndicats et les sous
traitants de la centrale de fessenheim
il dirigera aussi une réunion du comité
de pilotage à l'issue de laquelle on
espère avoir plus de précisions sur les
voies qu'ils comptent explorer pour ce
chantier de reconversion du bassin de
fessenheim merci beaucoup stéphane pour
ces précisions alors